est elle si on en croit les chiffres
d'olivier dussopt il y a peu de
grévistes aujourd'hui mais dans les rues
qu'en est il de la mobilisation à ce
qu'il ait suivi et bien grégory vous
allez pouvoir le voir derrière moi sur
ces images de nassim gomery derrière ce
cordon de forces de l'ordre ils sont
plusieurs milliers à déambuler dans les
rues de la capitale des manifestants qui
ont répondu à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale qui réclame le retrait
pur et simple du projet de réforme des
retraites alors dans ce cortège de
nombreux corps de métiers sont
représentés à l'image des avocats jeu
proposera d'écouter le secrétaire
général du syndicat des avocats de
france
on a eu un certain nombre de semaines de
mobilisation des semaines de grève qui
ont été extrêmement durs et le
gouvernement pour l'instant de cette
part l'objectif maintenant c'est passé
dans le temps long c'est de montrer
qu'on est déterminé qu on lâchera pas et
qu'on continuera à se mobiliser pendant
toute la durée du texte jusqu'à ce que
le gouvernement recule actuellement le
travail de conviction il est en train
d'être fait on a des sondages qui
montrent que 60 % des français veulent
maintenant que le gouvernement refuse
recul sur ce projet retire ce projet et
l'objectif c'est de montrer que la
détermination et à est de convaincre les
40% qui reste de ce projet néfaste et va
être va détruire nos retraites
voilà grégory pour les revendications le
cortège s'est élancé aux alentours de 14
heures depuis la gare de l'est
et il poursuit à sa route en direction
de la place de la nation